so this video may sound like a
relationship video to some it may be
this is actually a business video by the
time is saying you'll see what I mean by
so front of might call me yesterday he's
around 40 years old haven't spoken to
him for a while but I know he's been
with this one girl for some time and
about two years ago he and I were
talking he came out of a relationship
didn't work out and he says Pat I think
I'm finally at a point where I want to
settle down I want to get a wife
I'm gonna build a family he's been a
bachelor never been married no kids
nothing good guy
hard worker courier guy runs the real
estate business does good for himself
and I sat then I said so uh is this
pretty serious has no it's pretty
serious I said so tell me what you're
looking for
you said you know I want somebody that's
this somebody that's that somebody
that's this somebody that's that I said
how old are you wanting to go with a
girl he says well you know late 20s
early 30s he's 40 I said okay cool so
then after that he calls me he starts
telling me that he felt that he met this
girl and I said you met the school says
yeah I said Wow
so tell me about her well you know she's
20 years old she's about to turn 21 I
said and then she he goes through it
quickly she's 20 years about to turn 21
good girl
drop-dead gorgeous I really like her I
like her family she's got the right
values and principles I said wait wait
wait wait let's go back a little bit
back up a little bit he says what I said
how old did you say she was since he was
20 she's 20 so how are you 40 I said huh
said okay so they said I keep telling my
said orange you kind of getting away
from what you said you wanted your girl
to be on who you want her to settle down
since yeah but it's different I said
okay your goes by your lady he calls me
he says I don't know but she just
doesn't want to be in a serious
relationship I said what do you mean she
relationship I said she just doesn't I
don't know what I need to do maybe I
need to be patient do I do this I think
I made a mistake you know I think I
should have done this with or dad with
her I said I said I said listen listen
pump your brakes for a second I said are
you calling me because you just need
somebody listen to her you calling me
because you want counsel because I can
do both which one do you want no Pat I
actually want counsel today I said okay
fine
I said do I have your permission to be
direct with you said yes I said let me
ask you a question he says what's that
when when you and I were in our early
20s partying what what was the one word
that scared the hell out of us when we
would go on a date with a girl he says
what do you mean I said what's the one
word that that literally we would shake
we would have get the shingles you know
when a girl would use this word he says
what was it I said marriage the M word
the M word was the F word for us girl
and a date would say you know I just
want to find somebody and I want to have
kids and I want to get me I'm sorry what
did you just say yeah well yeah I mean
that's what people want to do right not
not this guy
no not this guy I have no desire to get
married or have kids and quite frankly I
don't think I'll ever get married or
have kids based on the state that I'm
right now 21 years old so us are all the
best I got some friends that go to
church I can introduce you to them this
guy goes to a different church on
Thursday night Friday night and Saturday
night it's I'm assuming it's not the
church you go to but there's some good
guys that you should meet this is not
the guy for you and he says yeah I
remember those days I said you are that
girl to the girl you're dating right now
he says what do you mean I said you told
her you want to get married and have
kids and she's 20 years old the two word
that Scarah scared the hell out of
somebody that doesn't want to be married
kids have kids you used just oh his
voice is I said what do you
expect what did we do you know when I
was single had no desire to get in a
serious relationship it was very simple
conversation look marry you look great I
like you it seems like we get along
pretty good if you want to have fun
together I'm all-in I don't want any
commitments I'm not have any desire to
do that I'm 21 years old I'm just trying
to have my fun if you want you won if
you don't you don't I don't have any
priorities in my life at that time my
priorities were pretty much partying I
didn't have a career that I want you're
just very disrespectful
the army and this was a lot of things
that I was doing I was having a good
time but it was clarity this is what I'm
doing right and then they had the
opportunity to say no I'm not interested
in that
no problem all the best to you or you
know what whatever you seem like a fungi
great you know but this is just a very
very simple relationship no problem okay
great
all good fast-forward to today what does
this have to do with you here's the
challenge most of the time most speed
luck for me when I got to Palmer I
wanted to get married here's what the
conversation sound like I was dating a
girl that uh you know she was a of
Shanna's Sade without being specific as
she was a pageant girl whatever I don't
want to give specific state so we really
like this girl we got along very well I
was another scholar and I'm trying to
give the safest words here anyway so
there was there was these other folks
that I was dating but I was not looking
to have just a girlfriend my line was
very simple I've done all the partying
I've had a lot of fun a lot of great
experiences and bad experiences with
women I've kissed many frogs I've been
to frog too many okay but I'm at a point
right now but I'm looking to settle down
and you know what it was great about
that comment those who got scared guess
what
phenomenal it's a filter those who said
oh okay Wow interesting let me see if
he's full of it or he's just using this
line because he read in the book and I'm
like this guy is actually pretty serious
he bought me a book called 101 questions
that's before you get engaged and I gave
that to every girl
I spoke to like here you go there you go
there you go and then after handful of
girls I did the exercise too with the
book then I made a decision I'm gonna go
on a second or third or fourth date with
and nothing against those girls by the
way every one of those girls that I
didn't date they're all married kids
happy all the best to them just didn't
fit and I moved on right moral the story
stop compromising your non-negotiables
if you say who you want to do business
with
they have to be willing to agree to
these three terms stop compromising your
non-negotiables stop giving up your
non-negotiables agree to amends stick to
them if you're dating somebody and
you're pretty clear on who you want to
date and all of a sudden you meet
somebody that's drop-dead gorgeous but
all the important stuff and life that
matter you're compromising to them I'll
choke ya look past it five ten years
later you're gonna pay a price for it
just so you know this it's a big price
get clear on what you want to do
friendship what are three
non-negotiables of somebody being a
friend in your life do you have the
answer data to that question what are
your three non-negotiables for somebody
be in a relationship with you a serious
one what are they do you know it don't
compromise it what are three
non-negotiables for someone doing
business with you what are three
non-negotiables for you to invest into
business what are deeply non-negotiables
for somebody to be your investor what
are three non-negotiables for somebody
for you to work with or some honor to be
your mentor or somebody have influence
over you what are they do you have three
non-negotiables what are your three
non-negotiables for your your kids
friends to be friends with your kids
what are they is what are three
non-negotiable for every aspect of your
life now watch this you ever met
somebody that's got 50 of them very
annoying people to be around because
you're always gonna break something the
list cannot be 30 or 40 or 50 it's
typically three and every time you
compromise one of them you're gonna pay
price for it and only one person can get
upset at you and it's you ask you
because you compromise your
non-negotiable so watching this video I
told you it's not about dating or
relationship it's all around around life
it's all about around life and it could
be business as well get clear on your
non-negotiables and don't compromise it
I've made mistakes and investing into
businesses individuals losing money a
lot of money hiring people that didn't
work friends that didn't work people
that didn't work dates investments so
many of them because I broke my
non-negotiable rules either I didn't
have the three or I broke one of them
because something seemed sexy and
attractive so stick your non-negotiables
trust it every once in a while you can
adjust your non-negotiable sometimes you
may say I think that one is too strong
I'm gonna change
I'm gonna add this to it but if you know
it in advance stick to it
I have non-negotiables on the way I
raise my kids I'm sticking to it may or
may not work that's what I'm doing very
simple
okay very that's what that's what I'm
sticking to so again going back to you
spend some time about these important
issues in life and don't let anybody
confuse you where you compromise it and
a long term it'll serve you well so I
got a video I want you to watch I make
this video I think the first or second
week of January the title of the video
is seven habits to help you dominate in
2019 I'm gonna put the thumbnail here I
want you to go watch this video okay
watch this video after this because they
have to do this goes a little bit deeper
into this topic so if you want to get a
little bit deeper into the stop and
click on this video 7 habits help adopt
and dominate in 2019 and then if you
haven't subscribed to the channel do so
and if you haven't if you have any
thoughts you want to share on this video
comment below as well and with that
being said have a killer week I love you
guys take care bye bye